ragazzi non saprei come cominciare
questo virus non con cominciamo a
giocare il prima possibile perché è una
vita che aspetto questo gioco
[Musica]
saab leon bene da my brother non c'è
nessuno
mamma mia beh io non andrei a
controllare poi fai tu
cioè io se fossi io io non sarei mai
andato a controllare una volta vista una
roba del genere prof
guardiamoci intorno è certo coming out
[Musica]
c'è nessuno
c'è qualcosa che non va sicuri che io
debba farlo adesso senza non ho armi
meno la gente salve secondo me non sta
benissimo però grazie averlo chiesto
subito questa indicando la maniglia
l'acqua dentro gli sta mandando in pasto
agli zombie in iran grande e questo
grazie fratello davvero non so come
ringraziarti permesso gente che succede
a queste la scena del trailer corto no
no no scherzavo incazzavo da una colata
e invece era proprio la scena del
trailer seccato non muoverti sparo al
cielo la pistola
mammamia rega quant'è brutto posto
no ci sta che 318 non bastino mi piace
fermarmi ad aiutare la gente insomma una
cosa che so fare bene per me è un 10 più
sfuggire al negozio allora ragazzi e mi
dispiace non so ancora
no ragazzi impossibile prova veramente
da parte gli scherzi ma quanti
proiettili devo spendere per uno zombie
regalo gli ho sparato sette volte sette
otto volte gli spari è impossibile
seriamente se per andare avanti nel
gioco così devo trovare munizioni ogni 4
secondi sono le finisco subito però ciao
amico c'era un tipo simpatico anni ha
inciso dentro concepito dentro no frate
faccio un'altra porta qua ok usa
lurido schifoso se ti becco ma ti spara
prescindevano anche se ti sei alzato eri
già zombie vabbè gli avrei sparato lo
stesso anche se fosse stato umano
ragazze aiuto non ho proiettili sono
solo un colpo non solo un colpo
porca vacca via via via via via ci sono
questo
salve
non ho più non ho più non ce l'ho più mi
attira gli schiaffi adesso è bene come
che sparo io e otto colpi lui spara una
colpa va beh
[Applauso]
io andrei via invece di star libero ok
abbiamo rubato l'auto della polizia
vabbè da mi aspettavo subito azione a
manetta
io non ho mai visto una ragazza più
bella di questa in tutta la mia vita
so che non serve a niente perché tanto è
codice di programmazione però se esisti
dovremmo noi abbiamo della fame sono
perdutamente innamorato anche di loro e
per carità meglio correre
mammamia regala buone
torniamo indietro the job seeker boldrin
vi va bene i ragazzi che non guido io
perché sennò saremmo morti si e molto
l'aveva e tir e camion
tieniti forte
e morto ad adesso è morto adesso è tutto
il tempo che avevano già dato problema
c'è è giusto e bloccato la strada per
non poter uscire grazie no per carità
siamo vivi per qualche miracolo divino
no scusami e la tipa cioè che succede
no
vabbè quando le giornate cominciano male
è vero ma secondo me no però peccato è
il peccato però
sì ma dovrei accelerare un attimo ok
va bene pescara france che faccio le
dove su di qua beh non mi sembra il
momento per capire cosa sta succedendo
in meno entriamo nella centrale quanti
colpi o uno perfetto questo sì che è un
buon momento per avere un colpo in canna
e che sto andando esattamente di
pagamento per la centrale
eccola da entrare ragazzi non ho niente
se non un colpo quindi o mi date colpi o
cielo nel campo anzi di brutto via via
via via via ti devi togliere questo
avevo questo usato non li posso più
usare corali e basta
cori e basta aprite meno male che ha
offerto non ha un problema con più di
studenti di più effetto in via di via li
vedi in via di lì molto meno signori
quei colpi avevo lì olio sfruttati tutti
incredibile ora o me ne date un milione
di colpi o un problema o la mi sembra di
riconoscere lo stop per oro di via ero
vestito diversamente lo sguardo c'è
nessuno è ufficialmente quella della
parte della demo però non lo colpì
quindi niente
diamo avanti per andare avanti di qua
keep out ovviamente io entro anzi posso
anche fare
ok my friends allora so esattamente dove
andare perché la demo giocata a due
settimane fa quindi mi ricordo tutto
poi non c'è ancora nessuno per tirare su
questo arrivo ma c'è un tizio che non fa
proprio una buona fine però va bene la
mia anche le gambe scherzavo
giovedì a roma chiamata in mano anzi
adesso mela filo visto che l'ultima te
sono stato qua un'ora e mezza e poi
stavo per morire perché se sei qua un
sacco per ivano zombie su zombie bello
però le interiora mi piace un sacco
vai vai vai veloce veloce ciao salve 12
o mancato porca vacca aumentato in
teoria non dovrei tipo morire subito una
cosa del genere
porca vacca che male aiuto non mi
ricordo che si esce di carico
porca vacca hanno inglobato in due via
via via dire velocissimi ragazzi e un
colpo sbagliato man azzannato il muro
problema mio
trento
grazie fratello sembrano leon kennedy
c'era un altro gente io sono certo che
hai fatto del suo meglio
ed ecco zannato tutte e due le spalle
però vabbè dettagli vede dettagli e
dovrei curarmi visto che mi hanno quasi
ucciso così no colpi ovviamente visto
gioco io so già che andrà a finire che
ogni 5 minuti avrò bisogno di colpi che
non avrò io sono giallo quindi non
vorrei utilizzare lo spray medico adesso
perché serve un po uno spreco qui
andiamo avanti
leg dovrei riuscire ecco la pianta
pianta averle mazza una pianta vera
posso curarmi si piccola parte di salute
vai perfetto sono già ripreso salute ore
sono schiacciavo allora 11 colpi ogni
dieci corpi sono quasi due zone quindi
devo veramente sfruttare al massimo i
colpi che oh che bello che sto giocando
sta parte senza che la l'ansia che
finisce la demo
mammamia rega questo faccia a faccia
mezza mangiata non ricordo purtroppo
[Musica]
ok quello e chewing gum comunque andiamo
avanti ma me lo ricordo il jump scheri
invece no niente ci sarà una volta in
cui riusciti a far parte tranquillo se
non erro c'era la tessera non hanno la
chiave wow e io avrei bisogno della
tessera per aprire non mi ricordo dove
si trovate saper trovare il fucile a
pompa crociera da qualche parte vabbè la
troverò cosa è stato non lo so ma non è
il momento di far riprendere danno
perché visto un altro pop sono morto
quindi piano
per cortesia non fate casino perché già
al casinò c'è già ho poca vita ma se le
sono studiate tutte le posizioni dove
metterli no perché mica go addosso come
niente sto gioco che vi giuro
la roba incredibile ma neanche outlast
c4 ma questo non lo toccherei tantissimo
mentre ci provo no non è saltato strano
piazza su qualcosa
non ho idea di cosa ci gioca sopra ma
sicuramente non ce l'ho questo deve
usare per far fuori grande meno male
perché stavo messo malissimo col menù
perfetto e andiamo avanti
per adesso ok arrivo arrivo un attimo un
attimo
ciò è un casino allora qua se non mi
ricordo male il pavimento va giù perché
la demo l'ho giocata quindi 321 a chi
saranno mettono sì però stai calmo pure
tu e che quanti ne mancano che sento
gente che camminava st quanta gente
basta tornate a casa oa questa la chiama
ok ho più che per questa guerra la
chiesa contrasto prima che peraltro non
ho ben capito dove portano a sì sì sì sì
sì l'avevo fatto anche nella demo che
allora abbiamo ufficialmente adesso era
finita la demo quindi tutto quello che
succede in bollo so adesso lui mi dice
qualcosa che non mi ricordo fratello
stai messo sempre meglio
lucky perina la conosci
si si chiama clero mi fa ridere perché
mi immagino sempre che mi faccia vedere
uno youtuber aprile dal piano di sopra
vado vado vado ha mosso la mano e
stuckey piro da apple
chi è buongiorno ecco qua non ce l'ho
mai stato quindi se trovo colpi o robe
schifo non mi fa prendiamo roba la
pianta si perché sto schiattando quindi
anzi combiniamo l'ha già effetto mix di
piante mi faccio capire un'altra volta e
poi la usa c'è una soda che si chiama
campa campa cavallo che l'erba l'ho già
trovata quindi andiamo avanti ragazzi e
lo zombie cielo pluri sparaco demonio
che è successo lì si è schiantato si è
fatto male che successo secondo me
questo non è un parcheggio però se la
vuoi parcheggi ecco a milano quando
girate con la macchina a un certo punto
mi viene da fare così perché il
parcheggio non si trova però sono
contento che lui l'abbia trovato tutto a
posto
secondo me è morto c'è poco da non sono
un detective è però mi viene è così da
pensarlo eccola la zia un'ora e mezza
per ritrovarla ciao aspetta arrivo
subito la tipa tra l'altro era era
circondata di zombie non ce n'è più
neanche uno come possibile il tipo ha
preso fuoco
tutto normale team allo state flirtando
ci sono degli zombie parlate in quando
siete al sicuro no no non arrenderti
sono certo che lo troveremo
tutto è bene quel che finisce bene una
storia esplosiva la vostra che dice di
andare avanti
city ho trovato le cesoie i proiettili
tutto trovato cavolo aspetta la con le
cesoie possa aprire le robe tipo la
porta anche che c'era dall'altra parte
quella che ciò che c'era all'inizio
avete capito
via via via via cesoie avrei cesoia ti
bravo fratello gli ha via via via via
via via permesso ciao giacomo non senti
ho bisogno di proietti perfetto
dispositivo elettronico tutto sto
trovando tutto adesso prima non ce l'ho
trovato niente del tutto ciò n'amo bene
via ha tra l'altro posso mettere
fusibile perfetto
anche se riaperta da forti già questo
già qua abbiamo risolto
magari posso già prendere un altro
oggetto di quelli che ho lasciato magari
non la stordente qua allora o la
manopola ho un po di cose che posso fare
adesso perché ho preso un poco molto di
oggetti sono manopola e diario che non
capitava da server e cesoie le usate la
manopola serve per andare al piano di
sopra io ci andrei a si è aperta proprio
la saraceni la chiuderei perchè sei qua
c'è gente ogni tanto quindi vediamo non
si può che fernando se entra qualcuno
gli spari e che qua ho aperto e dove è
morto e vabbè andiamo a testa portiamo
si apre bene ma la chiave prima o poi la
butto perché non è che mi posso portare
giovanni c'è anche lei allora che
sorpresa qua dovrei metterci
teoricamente anche praticamente la
manopola per o gira per i get my friends
tu stai fermo e giovanni che ti vedo che
c'e l'alitosi quali sento e mi sento non
ti si fermò e figurati è morto che
strano porcu schifo che salve no no no
no no no no no
tu chiamale cos'è sta roba qua ma non
sei in questo è il sum quando
trasformati in zombie ragazza aiuto
9 non muore mai poi immortale via via
via è una roba luce con schifo kia è
chiuso è tutto sblocca veloce si vabbè
non è vero che sfiga
continua ho sentiti operò fino a quando
ce l'ho passato aspetta eccolo eccolo
e ciò anche il libro ecco la wipo locker
ok siamo ok e combina manovra prima gli
ha staccato il braccio perché bambina
vabbè dai basta che gli e lo metti
adesso ma tutte ste robe dentro il
distretto di polizia per quale motivo
sono sti meccanismi strani strada non è
capito grazie lo scettro lodo in testa
la gente agli zombie uno scettro con
incastonato nel genova grazie muovendo
su ebay
c'è una roba dentro alla jim i cui
valori sembra essere molto alto che a me
ne vo regalia mackler che ha una gnocca
incredibile non dovrei apprezza non lo
so
mille anni dopo
dio mio dami giocattolo anni il
giocattolo grazie anch'io
servirebbe anche l'altro allo ragazzi
questo è il mio è la mia scrivania
adesso ci penso non l'avevo ancora
sbloccata ho già scritto lioness kennedy
atleti un caso molto speciale come primo
incarico la tua missione è accedere alla
tua scrivania usando le iniziali nei
nostri nomi inseriti nell'ordine delle
nostre postazioni ok rita phillips
marvin brand drm inserisce nell'ordine
le nostre impostazioni ho capito ma che
partendo da quale e non lo so allora
neal carsen n è ndm e di gehrig e manca
l'altra che sono e sarebbero l'ultimo
qua manca non c'è il nome nell'ultimo
che sfiga è cascato in terra lo so io
come ti chiami giovanni lo sparo a casa
m r qualcosa troviamo mr qualcosa m k
fgmg
ciò che sia l'ultimo grazie caricatore
maggiorato mali matilda va bene 15 o più
colpa perché mi ha dato dei colpi
quindi il che fa il traffico grazie
ragazzi peccato che siete tutti i morti
però saremo stati degli ottimi compagni
grazie mille gentili o mappa piani
superiori not bad perfetto adesso che
posso vedere i piani superiori che
facciamo
a caso ho provato a fare due rope ok
siccome raga sono attrezzato strabene
stavolta è il fucile a pompa e tutto io
andrei nella stanza questa qua di sopra
dopo le docce a far fuori lo zio
quello che non so riuscito a far fuori
con la pistola che imbattibile contro
fare almeno forse così ci posso provare
signori del momento pregate per me da
gianfranco ufficio stars perfetto per
questo perfetto perfetto chiuri a porta
non è intriga lo zio non entrare non
entra non entrato non entra nelle porte
bene questo è un ottimo questa è
un'ottima notizia
ok qua non c'era ancora entrato molto
bene
esploriamo batteria così posso far
saltare c4 innanzitutto circolare
interna tra circolati pasqua la
cassaforte ignifuga dotata di
combinazione a tre cifre o la
combinazione 9 15 set
very good abbiamo anche la combinazione
c'è di tutto qua dentro colpi tutto c'è
piena combina devo riuscire a correre
come un puledro adesso che c'è da fare
li sa che non ho giocato in primissimi
residenti va quindi non so un kit non so
bene come si battano però che non è che
c'è anche questo per salvare ciò che ci
siamo ma c'è tutto tranne qua il
computer se in fila la penna usb del
computer
thanks center installare minecraft cos'è
sta roba qua fornai che sto facendo
file di toti dove ad emettere una
chiavetta usb dentro il computer vale
non ce l'ho ha peccato ci un'altra arma
là dentro
va bene se trova la chiavetta usb che
probabilmente sarà dentro la cassaforte
quasi sicuro posso aprire sta roba
o la batteria facciamo saltare in aria
il c4 agli altri meno male che ho
trovato tutti gli oggetti perché stavo
messo veramente da cani lo stavi
parlando
allora lì sopra
ormai la sua memoria stava c'è un
macello e poi in teoria dovremmo passare
oltre il settore polizia
teoricamente allora la batteria vacua se
tutto va bene dovrebbe saltare in aria
perché se no non so proprio che fare
altro gli altri a lo devo combinare il
pivot detto sì per quanto c'è di tempo
zero lo metto esplode usa 10 9 via porca
vacca allah è grande o che analizza un
visto ancora dentro che è successo e
succede che era sta lì tata non balzate
perché sto sentendo il rumore che non mi
piacciono
eccolo qui questo è l'ultimo codice
quanto pare no ragazzi abbiamo tutto
tutto devo solo aprire le cose con i
codici e basta allora taccuino della
gente e ci sono segnali ci sono proprio
segnati che pirla allora questo le
l'unicorno cielo l'avevo provato a caso
ma ce l'avevo in realtà quest'altro è
donna arco serpente don marco serpente
donna arco serpente
ari gold e ciò il secondo e il terzo nel
salone centrale che quello che ancora mi
manca che lo possa aprire facendo beta
quindi leone ulivo e aquila
torniamo nel settore centrale e abbiamo
finito per strano come che vale forte
come ha fatto entrare questo porco
demonio via via via via velocissimo come
ha fatto entrare mi ha fatto non mi ha
fatto quasi niente che strano no so good
tutti e tre
ce l'abbiamo tutti e tre ragazzi manca
niente quindi adesso vedo che cosa mi ha
sbloccato come fatto per fare mentre la
attiva la statua della dea allo zio qua
è morto cosa è successo
frate a posto secondo me non sta
benissimo però valido mettere in un
certo ordine tipo no a casa
manca uno il medaglione di gianfrancesco
ci siamo sbloccati tutto cosa sta porta
qua e lei sa come uscire mi spiegano
tutte ste robe in un settore di polizia
cosa che ci facevano troppo aveva sotto
terra che non è il massimo
usciremo da quindi franco organ bari da
quanto ci fai temo che non è morto ma
signori salta addosso adesso dentro
attento attento la portiamo subito in
ospedale
no no mi sa che questo titolo è ancora
cosciente penso che tipo di forza
l'aiuto possiamo ancora uscire insieme
le moine adesso gliele fi dopo tanti ci
ho provato lio
ora è troppo tardi mi dai colpi della
pistola impostiamo lasciarlo diffondere
ora tocca a te
adesso mai
va bene sa proprio che si chiude dietro
a quindi non posso più accedere a tipo
all'altra cassaforte al cose della
chiavetta peccato male dai quindi siamo
proprio davanti va beh e peccato perché
c'erano ancora delle robe dovuto
trovarvi la gru completamente territorio
inesplorato adesso adesso sì che sono
tranquillo quindi ragazzi questo è il
primo episodio residenti volo fatto un
pochettino più lungo perché la parte
questa politica della stazione di
polizia era l'avete già vista nel
avevate già vista nella demo ovviamente
non completa che sopra completata ed
possiamo bisogno ci sono tutte le zone
nuove e niente spero che video vi sia
piaciuto è una bomba residenti vuole
veramente difficile come al solito
ragazzi se vi è piaciuto il documento è
un mi piace anche i vari social che come
descrizione se ne sono usciti siete lì e
noi ci chiediamo come sempre ad un
prossimo video beh ragazzi
[Musica]